and now for the Music Awards to present
them a fellow who's been hanging around
the music shops for a long long time
this kid was humming a tune when Gilbert
and Sullivan were total strangers old
leather tonsils himself mr. Bing Crosby
right
all right Sam you're funny too much for
you get to the Torah this is the first
jar I have to perform is to announce the
winner for the best scoring of a musical
picture on the winner Seven Brides for
Seven Brothers
begin with your buddy thank you may we
thank Gd Paul Johnny Mercer and Michael
kid for helping us win these Oscars
now for the best score for a comedy or a
dramatic picture the winner high and the
mighty Dimitri Thompson
ladies and gentlemen because they are
working in this town for 25 years I like
to make some kind of appreciation to
very important factor what makes me
successful a lot of my colleagues in
this town I like to think Johann Brahms
the other Strauss
man
Corsica
you'll never get on this show again
and now the next awards for the best
song written for a motion picture three
coins
you
thank you going to take one Sam you just
going to walk up to make you sociable
say a few words
mm I would like to add one statistic to
the minute I counted 27 steps from my
seat the podium
it took us 14 years to get thank you
very much
look dad even though you were nominated
you can still talk to old friends you
know after all I'm master of ceremonies
here yes they they couldn't get George
Gobel after all China no we couldn't get
Gary either that's why you have no
straight clothes don't mess around
poppy you know why not in my next
picture on muscling into your territory
was that in the seven little boys thank
you little bugger little broad in it why
bring love forget free corn bone you'll
get a bite or barbecue I did hear about
your work in that picture now I hear
that you you really knock off some pilot
dramatic scenes yes and I do it without
a drink
you know that might be your problem
I'd see this day being entails what
miracle hath Jim Clinton rocks
I'm glad II get that back to the
headwaiter at Lucy's right away he
called me earlier Nev he wanted me to
dress him didn't know whether the tails
went inside or outside it's better when
he's off isn't it huh I don't want to
take advantage of dad now that he's
offstage because he's really it's a
wonderful job he didn't country girl and
he's nominated in fact he should have
been he was born on the stage you know I
think it was the one that went from
Tulsa to Dodge City
in those days he was a used ox cart
dealer